now these Democrat leaders they're
finally seeing maybe how dangerous these
Sanctuary policies are but they should
have seen this Crisis coming we all did
it shouldn't take violent assaults of
their residents to get them to rise up
and start fighting back
my next guest lives just down the block
from one of those nearly 200 shelters in
New York City and he says a few weeks
ago illegals were bust in the middle of
the night to the Stratford Arms Hotel
and since then
it's just been wreaking havoc on the
neighborhood there joining me now is Joe
germanata he's a restaurant owner and
known as father to Lady Gaga no I'm not
calling you Daddy Gog I promise you Joe
um tell us tell us what you're seeing is
it drugs is it is it fights what is it
well it's mostly
um it's mostly noise and chaos and motor
motorbikes and loitering and trash and
recently prostitution
so I mean to give you a little bit those
are migrants being prostituted out I I
don't know whether they're coming out of
the hotel or going into the hotel I
don't think they can go into the hotel
but they're just hanging out in the
center of Broadway now which you know
that used to happen in the 70s right I
mean that's that was but I mean to give
you the backdrop I mean within four
blocks there's five elementary schools
all right and
you know they're all PR there's Pre-K
students we had we had a summer camp
there this this past summer I mean and
the loitering has become a problem it's
a noise at night one of the one of the
Condominiums at the end of the block
they hired their own security you know
we haven't we haven't gotten much help
from NYPD although they are starting to
listen tomorrow I have a meeting with uh
the chief of Patrol from uh One Police
Plaza and
we realize you know we have to we have
to work together to get something done
but there is no plan
they just they dropped them into the
neighborhood right all of a sudden 500
new people were in the neighborhood and
they took over and it's just there was
no advanced warning it just happened in
the middle of the night they you know
they threw the college kids out yeah
yeah I think Joe the problem here is
that for the longest time I think a lot
of the urban areas felt like they were
immune to the problems of illegal
immigration and now that illegal
immigration is like seven million people
have come here
you know they're not going to just stay
in Texas even if they weren't shipped
out so I think everybody in the country
has to realize this is not just a Texas
and an Arizona problem this is a
national problem that's having profound
effects on our Great American cities and
our in our suburbs are now dealing with
it as well so but what has it done to
your business
well a lot of people a lot of the
immigrants are coming into the
restaurant looking for work
um it's a lot of the foot traffic at
night has slowed down
um you know it used to be you know a
high foot traffic area on Columbus
Avenue and Broadway I mean it's become a
no-fly zone so to speak I mean at late
at night you know from 10 o'clock at
night until about four in the morning
it's a Party Zone all right it's uh you
know oh my God
yeah it's it's so I mean this it's not
the New York that I certainly remember
from the 90s and early 2000s this is
this is in some ways a hellscape we've
got about 15 seconds just final final
word to the country about this well now
I understand what Texas went through
with the migrant situation and you know
something's got to change all right in
the city of New York we're going to get
clobbered it financially and taxpayers
are going to have to flit the bill all
right I don't know whether the
government's ever going to step in Joe
thank you for alerting us uh to what
you're dealing with personally we really
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else